okay so the topic of this video is
homeostasis and the body's ability to
maintain an internal balance so let's
get started
okay so homeostasis is the process where
the body maintains a constant internal
environment and the reason this is so
important is because the internal
chemical reactions that are taking place
right now to keep us alive you know they
were they depend upon enzymes to help
perform these chemical reactions and
enzymes work in very very specific
conditions for example the human body
98.6 degrees Fahrenheit 37 degrees
Celsius if our body temperature rises or
Falls it fluctuates too far away from
this normal setpoint then many of those
internal chemical reactions just won't
proceed the enzymes lose their ability
to function and so we have control
systems in place in order to maintain
our not just our body temperature but
what else is controlled the percentage
of our blood sugar for example and the
pH of our blood if any of these levels
deviate too far from normal we could
suffer some pretty severe side effects
so let's talk about the control systems
in place in order to maintain our
homeostatic levels well let's begin with
the sensors or the receptors what they
do is they gather information about the
body and the environment in this example
in the skin of the woman's fingers our
thermal receptors these are heat
receptors notice she's getting too close
to a candle and so the heat is going to
activate her communication systems in
other words messages are going to be
sent through the body in order to
respond signals in this case an
electrical signal called an impulse will
travel up the woman's arm and into her
brain well speaking of the brain we now
have the control center and what the
control center does it receives
information from the sensors and in this
case it's it's the brain the brain is
interpreting this impulse as a
temperature impulse and the brain is
gonna respond by sending a signal to the
target the target is the body part that
needs to change its activity in this
case the brain is gonna send a signal
back to the hand and so in this case the
hand would be the target and the hand
has muscles that can pull away and
remove the fingers from the heat to
prevent any further damage so a good
example of the various control systems
maintaining balance
okay let's start talking about the
feedback loops that exist in order to
maintain our homeostatic levels let's
first start talking about negative
feedback this is what regulates most of
the body and in this process negative
feedback it's the process where your
body will reverse when a change is
occurring now before we go into biology
examples here's a simple analogy of
negative feedback in your home here's a
blueprint of someone's home pretend and
maybe tucked away in the utility room is
the furnace and mounted on the wall
somewhere and in the home is the
thermostat
now the thermostat and the furnace are
connected with a wire now you don't see
the wire because it's behind the walls
but it's there and of course coming out
of your furnace are all the heating and
air-conditioning vents and ducts that
will eventually bring warm air
throughout your home and let's pretend
you set the thermostat for 77 degrees
Fahrenheit but in reality let's pretend
it's only 74 degrees inside your home
and so what happens your thermostat will
turn on and send a signal to your
furnace your furnace will receive the
signal and blow out a bunch of heat
through the heating ducts and over time
over the next couple minutes 74 degrees
becomes 75 75 to 76 76 to 77 now that
the reality has matched the setpoint
everything turns off this is a great
example in your home of negative
feedback because your thermostat has
reversed the cold change that was
occurring within your house well let's
look at some actual biological examples
next okay so in this situation we have a
young child who's maybe been playing
outside and the cold and in the snow in
the middle of the winter and if the you
know the longer you're outside you're
exposed to the coldness of winter and
your temperature your body temperature
will start to lower well 98.6 degrees
let's pretend that's our core body
temperature but the longer you're
outside you can see what's happening
the child's body temperature is dropping
and eventually it gets to the point
where we start to shake and shiver
well the shakin in the Shivering is
designed to generate heat you know
muscles rubbing against other muscles
this creates friction and heat and over
the the next few minutes look what's
happening to our body temperature it's
coming back closer to normal
all this shivering has produced enough
heat to rewarm the body and get us back
to our normal setpoint of 98.6 degrees
well the opposite of this is true as
well here we have a young lady at the
beach a nice hot day and the longer
she's out exposed to the heat of the day
look what's happening to her core body
temperature it's increasing from 98.6
now we're up to ninety nine point seven
hundred point one and eventually we all
start to sweat and perspire well how
does this actually cool us down well as
the the sweat evaporates it pulls some
of our heat away from our body so the
more we sweat the more the sweat will
evaporate and pull more heat away from
our body and as the sweat evaporates the
heat is removed from our body and
eventually we get back to our set point
of 98.6 degrees notice negative feedback
reversed the change that was occurring
okay so then what's positive feedback
then well the myth first of all the myth
is that positive feedback is good for
you and negative feedback is bad for you
but the reality is that both positive
and negative feedback are crucial to
your survival
you know the examples we just discussed
with negative feedback those are very
important to your survival the reason
it's called negative to negative
feedback is because your body is
reversing a change that's happening to
you so what's positive feedback then
this is where your body will encourage
or promote a change before we go into
biological examples let's again look at
an analogy in your home scattered
throughout your home our smoke alarms
let's pretend in the middle of the night
a fire starts the smoke alarm close
- the fire will probably detect the
smoke first and send out that loud
piercing noise now all your smoke alarms
are connected to one another and so when
the first one is activated it will send
out an alert to all the other smoke
alarms throughout your home
and they all turn on and they make that
loud piercing noise to hopefully wake
everybody up to get you to safety
a great example of positive feedback
because the alert has been encouraged
well let's look at some biological
examples of positive feedback you know
first thing to mention is that positive
feedback loops tend to happen when a
rapid change is needed I already said
earlier that the majority of your body
is maintained by negative feedback so
positive feedback is a little more rare
so when a rapid change is needed let's
talk about for example when a woman is
about to give birth
she begins pregnancy contractions and in
the uterus you know the uterus is where
the baby grows for nine months there are
muscles and when the baby is about to be
born the muscle contractions start to
squeeze and eventually will help to push
and deliver the child but at first these
muscle contractions begin very slowly
well that's gonna stimulate a nerve in
the woman's us cervix to send a signal
up her spine into her brain the brain
will receive that signal and send out a
hormone by the name of oxytocin and
those black triangles are symbolic of
the hormone and what do you think this
hormone is gonna cause those muscle
contractions to do well I ask yourself
if this was negative feedback what would
happen next
if this was negative feedback then those
hormones would end the contractions but
if that happens the baby is never going
to be delivered so we don't want to use
negative feedback in this example in
this example positive feedback is going
to encourage these muscle contractions
it's going to encourage the change and
what we mean by that is the muscle
contractions are going to speed up much
more rapidly
oxytocin is a hormone that helps to
speed up these muscle contractions so
the baby can be born and delivered
quicker and then the mom and the child
are on the road to recovery
okay so you know changing directions
here the body works together in order to
maintain homeostasis there's no one body
part whose job it is to maintain
homeostasis it's you really it's your
whole body working together and we see
that beautifully in what we call thermal
regulation the maintaining of our body
temperature we're gonna see a lot of
variety of body parts working together
in order to accomplish this for example
let's say your your skin has sensors and
nerves on it to detect cold and so there
is the first part of working together is
your skin is detected cold temperatures
well what's gonna happen next is that
nerve the nerves in the skin will send
an electrical signal to your brain so
now we're we're using the nervous system
in order to send that electrical signal
that you are cold to the brain well now
the brain will receive that electrical
signal and the brain will respond by
sending out these little black triangles
or hormones hormones are our chemicals
that are released into your bloodstream
and so now we're using the endocrine
system to release the hormone and we're
also using the circulatory system to
pump the blood and where those hormones
going but those hormones are going to
our muscles so now we're bringing in the
muscular system and when the muscles
receive these hormones they begin to
stretch and contract very vigorously and
that causes our shivering and we said
earlier that the shivering will generate
heat to eventually warm us back to our
our setpoint but again just a really
nice example of the many parts that are
working together to maintain our
homeostatic levels
okay so from time to time our
homeostatic levels are disrupted now in
many cases these disruptions are
temporary
you know you do enough pull-ups like the
gentleman in the picture here you're
gonna get some sore muscles but that's
soreness is only temporary after maybe a
day or so it's gone
same with for example we've all probably
been bedridden at various times or we've
had a bad cold or maybe the flu or some
other infection that maybe really harmed
us for a couple days or so but
eventually our immune system fought it
off and we recovered but some
disruptions are actually too great for
your body to control now you can see the
the toes and the fingers of this person
this person has suffered from very
severe frostbite and even though their
body tried to warm them up by shaking
and shivering it just wasn't enough
to to prevent this damage and so this
person was exposed to extreme cold and
the sensors in their toes and in their
hands are probably destroyed and and and
you can see the toes in particular are
turning black I mean the cells of those
toes are dead so unfortunately you know
there's no way to you know surgically
recover from this when we look at for
instance this picture of the spine you
know people who suffer from paralysis
well first of all when your brain wants
to send a signal let's say you want to
kick a soccer ball the brain will send a
signal down your spine the signal goes
to your feet and then you eventually
kick the soccer ball but in the case of
paralysis let's pretend that there is an
injury to this area of the spine here
your your brain can still send a signal
down the spine but eventually when the
signal reaches the injured area the
signal can't can't continue to the to
the lower part of the body and this
person would be called a paraplegic they
don't have the ability to to move
really below the waist well you can
imagine if the injury were higher on the
spine this could be more devastating the
brain can only send a signal down a very
small portion of the spine before the
injure the site of the injury is has
occurred and now the signal has nowhere
to go and this person would probably be
labeled as a quadriplegic
they don't have the ability to use their
forelimbs
so unfortunately there is a growing
amount of people being diagnosed with
diabetes and let's talk about this first
so here are some cells and the cells
need glucose if you remember glucose is
the fuel that your mitochondria will
take in in order to make ATP your
mitochondria performs the action called
cellular respiration so your cells need
glucose and after a meal amount of
glucose G for glucose begins to
accumulate in your bloodstream this is
because your foods being digested and
the glucose is entered your bloodstream
well this will send an alert to your
brain that your blood sugar is getting
high
okay well notice that the glucose levels
are higher right now in your blood but
those blue doorways that could allow the
glucose into your cells are closed so
what happens is your pancreas will
respond by releasing insulin into your
bloodstream and so here comes a bunch of
letter I eyes the I stands for insulin
so this is insulin from your pancreas
it's gonna actually insulin is gonna
help open these glucose channel doorways
and as the insulin is received those
blue channel doorways begin to pop open
and now the glucose can diffuse from a
high concentration to a low
concentration into your cells and so
glucose as I just said will diffuse from
the high to a low concentration into
your cells thus given your cells
much-needed nutrition in the in at the
same time the glucose level in your
blood has gone back down and the alert
is gone negative feedback has returned
the glucose to normal levels in your
body
okay well well what's the problem then
what's diabetes well first of all the
process kind of starts the same people
who are a diabetic their cells need
glucose as well mitochondria will use
the glucose to make ATP and so after a
meal after a person has a meal the
glucose is digested and it enters into
the bloodstream so the glucose levels in
the blood have risen and so like we saw
before those doorways those blue glucose
and doorway channels are closed so it's
the job of the pancreas to release
insulin but people who are a diabetic
often have a problem in this maybe
they're damaged pancreas can release
only a small amount of insulin well this
will cause maybe a couple of the of the
glucose channels to or to open but the
vast majority of them have stayed closed
and so for the couple cells where the
glucose channels did open glucose will
diffuse into those cells and they can
yeah take the glucose to make ATP but
the other cells are not getting the
glucose they need to survive and so
notice how the glucose level in the
blood has never returned to normal the
alert is still there the blood sugar
glucose levels are still too high
well as the hours pass let's say the
person has another meal the glucose
levels are already high and on top of
that the problem is compounded by having
another meal and so with the other meal
comes even more glucose and so now the
glucose levels are really out of balance
and at this point ironically the cells
begin to starve even though the glucose
the food is so close it's so nearby it's
just on the other side of their cell
membrane they begin to starve because
they're not able to make ATP they're not
able to get the glucose to make ATP
and the amount of glucose actually
alters the pH remember we said earlier
at the beginning of these notes the
normal pH of blood is seven point three
five the the pH of the blood actually
falls into the acidic range and this
alters a lot of the chemical reactions
that are needed to survive and here are
some of the the negative side effects of
diabetes heart disease high blood
pressure stroke and and even even death
well how how is diabetes how's it tend
to be treated well with insulin
injections so in this case a person can
inject themself with the letter I for
insulin and by injecting insulin into
the blood stream this will this insulin
will cause those closed channels to open
and once they are open I think you see
where this is gonna go the glucose will
diffuse into the cells and over time the
blood sugar will hopefully go back down
to normal
okay and as we wrap up this video here
here's a little practice quiz for you to
try see how you can do answering these
questions and if you're in my biology
class I'm happy to check your answers
before a class or after class one day
thanks for watching